I'm just packing my bag for Alaska and
if you want to know why I'm going to
Alaska well you're not the only one
it seems I've become the y-guy on a new
morning show on channel 10 called
breakfast now just saying why you saying
something you thought something you're
just gone why well that's why we have my
guy dr. Derek Muller he's here to answer
all the questions so I'm gonna play you
a clip of the live interview I did this
morning talking about why I'm going up
to Alaska and the one that I had pouring
right now is what is a solar book is is
the Sun got indigestion what's going on
with this yeah well it's actually not
really called the solar Burke but a
solar flare or a coronal mass ejection
but you can basically think of it as the
Sun getting out of Berk which is
Belcher's pieces of itself into space
and these are the images that we're
saying because this is this only happens
every now and then doesn't well
basically every 11 years a bit like
clockwork the Sun will break out in
spots and start spewing out these these
hot gases fast-moving charged particles
and it just sprays it out into space why
Derek why well the Sun has is made of
plasma and it has these big big magnetic
fields within it and they get all
bunched up coiled up every 11 years and
they sort of spring outwards to a lower
energy state when they do that they send
all this matter out into space but why
Derek the other question I have is what
what effects does this have on us here
on earth do we have any kind of
impeccable well there are some beautiful
effects if we get just a bit of it it'll
create the aurora the beautiful northern
or southern light right so you can see
there's ever times mania or even over
the North Pole around there but there
can also be some negative impacts they
can knock out our satellites they can
destroy they can destroy satellites it
can cause problems with our power grids
how long just expect it to last for a
few years so every 11 years it's sort of
there's a peak for about a year or two
but there's nothing for us to worry
about from the hall you know that
concept of a solar flare being big
enough just doing don't fuss and that's
it game over I know we're far enough
away from the Sun that by the time it
reaches ice it's the solar flares
basically spread out and you're now on
the Rick of saying that no one can hold
you out that's right well the UK has
actually added the sort of solar
activity to their list of national
security threats so you know if the
storm is big enough but the Sun is now
terrorist
in a way yeah in 1989 all the power was
knocked out to Quebec because of one of
these silver charms yeah now I'm very
jealous you're heading up to Alaska
you're talking about the aurora what are
you going to do when you get there or
what we're gonna go do is launch HD
cameras on weather balloons and we're
gonna send them up into the stratosphere
so we're the first team ever to do this
and we're gonna look at the aurora from
inside film it in HD in color so how you
gonna find these other things you're
sneaking up them with a bull angel
something how you gonna track them down
because I got they're not gonna come
down what you want yeah so we're gonna
have to put some sort of homing beacons
on them and then we're gonna have to
trick out through the wilderness on dog
sleds and choppers and stuff to try to
find this stuff so what are you gonna do
when you get that vision do we get a
chance to have a look at only a big
screen
absolutely all coming out I'll bring it
back we can have a look at what we see
why Derek well I think everyone wants to
know know more about it and if we know
more about it hopefully we can you know
predict these solar events in future and
we can be better prepared you know it
can expose a lot of people to radiation
so if you're flying over the polls you
might actually have to have your your
fly tree routed if you're gonna get hit
by this this burst of particles coming
from the Sun so it does actually have
some common it has major impacts on us
yeah it's a it's a significant threat I
have one more question for you he it
says he that the total energy radiated
by the Sun averages 383 billion trillion
that sends my top billion trillion what
does kilowatts there you go okay yeah
it's still ridiculous um but it's a cute
ridiculous number if we brought it up
here we take the whole board to write it
up I mean the Sun it emits a crazy
amount of energy but most of it doesn't
hit the earth of course because all of
that energy spreads out in space so we
just get a tiny fraction of it well I
could sit here and say why old died
there thank you so much
if you want to see more of the show you
may want to check out the link in the
description and if you want to see more
of me on the show you may want to
comment or write them an email let them
know that other than that I guess I'll
see you guys on the flipside
see you in Alaska